counting the homeless in Clark County
this morning volunteers and County
officials conducted surveys with
homeless people in our community Candace
Charles shows us the process and
explains how it's meant to help
it's a count that could translate to
Millions for those who count our
unhoused community members and nearly
200 volunteers showed up to North Las
Vegas city hall Thursday morning ready
to help
it's 5 a.m fueled and informed these
volunteers are preparing for a busy
morning their task to count the unhoused
on the streets of Southern Nevada so I
decided to come to my part and get those
numbers for the government so we can get
that assistance and the funds for the
community volunteers were dispersed to
several locations across Clark County
including here where we found volunteer
Martin Castro handing out goodie bags to
on Owen in Maine so a little incentive
counting and conducting short surveys of
willing unsheltered people it was not
hard to see the need Clark County
Commissioner Justin Jones tells me the
annual homelessness census is a
qualifying requirement for more than 15
million a year and grant money to help
organizations provide homeless services
and programs and it's really important
not only to just give an assessment of
where we are in terms of addressing
homelessness but really it goes into the
millions of dollars in federal funding
that we get in order to address
homelessness the 2022 homeless census
found down more than 5 500 people living
in shelters are on the street there's
been a concern that number may be
greater this year frantically trying to
you know address those issues and help
folks as quickly as possible to either
Stave off that that housing crisis or
end their homelessness as quickly as
possible if you like to donate or
volunteer Clark County recommends
reaching out to the Nevada homeless
Alliance we'll have details on our
website newsnow.com for now Newsroom I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now